[Música]
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden registra un 41% de aprobación
entre los votantes de acuerdo con la más
reciente encuesta de bizi news y the
washington post la casa blanca espera
aliviar la presión sobre la actual
administración con el ambicioso plan de
infraestructura pero los resultados del
sondeo no vislumbran un escenario
optimista para los demócratas a un año
de las elecciones de medio término del
próximo año 2022 el resultado se conocía
de más una semana después de que otra
encuesta esta elaborada por hits de la
universidad de software que indicara que
el mandatario tiene tan solo un 38 por
ciento de la población entre todos los
votantes de eeuu y para ello quiero
saludar entonces en este momento a
roberto izurieta el profesor y director
de proyectos para américa latina en la
escuela de gerencia política de la
universidad george washington gracias a
roberto por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 qué pasa
con la popularidad del presidente
estadounidense joe biden
es la economía generalmente la economía
y la seguridad son las dos variables más
fuertes para determinar la popularidad
del presidente
muchas veces otra variable importante es
la comparativa las personas los votantes
pueden no simpatizar de un candidato por
estas razones u otras pero el candidato
contrincante tiene una imagen muchísimo
peor entonces esas variables son las que
explican el procedimiento
respectivamente la inflación en los eeuu
la subida de los precios sobre todo por
ejemplo la gasolina y lo que se llama la
irrupción en la cadena de sus ministros
que ha subido también los precios además
de comodidades yo diría que ahí están
gran parte de las razones que explican
esa cita
ahora también roberto quería preguntarle
si la sombra del expresidente donald
trump también como que nubla lo que está
haciendo el gobierno de dubai en este
momento la administración de joe biden
si es que está en la próxima elección o
era una elección entre trump y bailén lo
más probable a pesar de estas cifras va
a ir en ganaría pero todo indica que eso
no será segundo en este momento la gente
está concentrada en su situación de la
familia de la economía y recordemos a la
economía estaba bastante bien la
variable delta complicó las cosas no
solamente en términos de temores de
precauciones sino también complicó las
cosas en el suministro de la cadena
productiva entonces eso generó más
inflación y la inflación es una de las
cosas que más hacen que maxwell en a los
políticos es un sangrado político la
inflación además roberto todo esto pasa
en unas fechas claves para estados
unidos que vienen pronto hablamos en el
día de acción de gracias y también la
navidad la impresión de eeuu como usted
lo decía se ha esperado 6.2 por ciento
la mayor salto registrado desde
1990 digamos entonces que la un
estadounidense como casi todas las del
mundo se mueve por la economía para
elegir a sus mandatarios digamos que si
esto se soluciona posiblemente una
encuesta futura podría favorecer más al
presidente joe biden o digamos que ya el
presidente joe biden se estancó en una
media de este 40% para abajo
cuáles son las posibilidades y la
perspectiva que la inflación baje cuáles
son las perspectivas y las posibilidades
sobre todo que el precio del petróleo y
por lo tanto el precio de la gasolina
bajó sin lugar a dudas no para acción de
gracias' de acción de gracias' es un
momento donde la gente se moviliza mucho
por avión y sobre todo por tierra
entonces pagar esa factura va va a ser
muy impopular políticamente para la
mayoría de los ciudadanos y después de
acción de gracias viene el loc siam el
black friday la gente sale a comprar las
cosas que quiere regalar en navidad
los precios de muchas de las cosas que
quieren comprar están muy altos y muchas
de esas cosas no no se la puede
conseguir y las personas que están y se
va a ser otro problema que han ordenado
sus productos muchos de ellos no
llegarán a tiempo entonces todo esto va
a ser un ambiente en el cual la gente no
está contenta ahora las apuestas dice
pues veamos qué pasa en febrero de marzo
donde el precio del petróleo quizás
bajes donde la cadena de suministros se
regularice
donde se comienzan a ver señales de este
paquete de inversión de infraestructura
pues podríamos hablar en otro escenario
pero los próximos dos meses está
bastante claro que su popularidad va a
seguir estando afectada por estas
variables esa popularidad roberto
también se ve afectada por la migración
recordemos ya en ese año de gestión del
presidente joe biden que ha tenido
varias crisis migratorias en la frontera
el sur o con méxico los migrantes
centroamericanos los migrantes haitianos
la situación que hubo en texas con esta
población inmigrante haitiana esto
también ha afectado la popularidad del
presidente de byd en
absolutamente y el otro hecho que
también le afectó dramáticamente pues la
salida la salida bruta y desordenada de
afganistán entonces efectivamente la ha
tenido difícil es porque si vamos vemos
secuencialmente todos los problemas
han sido es una explicación real porque
está con esas cifras este de la
información de la migración se está más
controlado del tema de afganistán
yo diría se estaban se ha procesado un
poco mejor en el sentido de que muchos
de los norteamericanos creen que no
había realmente mayor solución habrían
esperado una salida más ordenada pero
pero en este momento es sin duda lo que
más duele es la inflación ahora también
hablando de otro punto clave que ha
pasado en eeuu por supuesto en el mundo
la pandemia alcor bit 19 esto también ha
sido otro factor que le ha bajado la
popularidad al presidente vayan a la
administración demócrata
si yo soy de los que todavía está por
verse los números han subido pero yo no
percibo y no he visto ninguna encuesta
donde la gente esté realmente muy
preocupada la preocupación ha aumentado
los números ha aumentado pero
considerando de que se está en proceso
primero el proceso de vacunación ha ido
avanzando agresivamente pero más
importante de que se están aprobando
vacunas de vacunas sino medicinas de
tratamiento
yo tengo una percepción que eso es menos
grave ahora dicho esto recordemos que
cuando apareció la variable de alta eso
ya es en la administración baile que las
cifras subieron a pesar de la vacunación
radicalmente en ese momento sin lugar a
dudas de observación era cien por ciento
correcta la cambio el ánimo de los
votantes porque nuevamente tenían miedo
y tenían miedo de que poder tengamos que
volver a otro rock se llama un la cam
black down encerrarnos en nuestras casas
eso al buen inicio fue fuerte después
y yo que no porque no va a ser tan grave
como el del año pasado pero yo hago como
voto que así sea que no sea algo
incontrolable roberto rápidamente para
finalizar no quiero despedirlo sin
hacerle esta pregunta de cara a las
elecciones de medio término que es
realmente lo que está en juego horita
políticamente en eeuu como está el punto
el pulso entre demócratas y republicanos
si es que las elecciones fueran hoy lo
más probable que los demócratas
perderían ambas cámaras pero la lección
no es hoy entonces todavía queda mucha
agua por correr y hay que seguir
monitoreando para ver si estas variables
que hemos descrito se van estabilizando
yo diría alrededor de marzo